tutoyer pas quelque chose tout le
paysage
voilà vous avez trouvé c'est la barrière
lâche rien mais les vents trop bon jour
c'est françois civil pour août
c'est un nageur doc au but
les blondes
je trouve ça beaucoup plus sexy de
rencontrer un inconnu dans un bar que de
choisir sur photos parmi cinq ou six
mecs mais après je sais qu'il ya des
gens pour qui c'est génial pour
rencontrer des gens bastien balt ans
parce que l ont pas le courage de les
aborder directement et que et que voilà
ça mais bon personnellement je trouve ça
moins septien je suis un peu triste mois
le côté le côté jugement ultra hâtif sur
l'emballage et sur justement comment la
personne décide elle même de seconde
seront tues mais des photos et on se
soit 28 et au marché quoi et j'ai
l'impression que il ya plein de filles
avec qui moi j'ai pu être dans ma vie
qui peut-être était pas totalement dans
si je les avais vu en photo peut-être
que j'aurais dit non et en fait j'ai
vécu des super truc avec et donc je me
dis que ça freine un peu ce que la
stable donc on s'est un peu tassée après
il est super rencontre sans doute qu'il
soit avec ça mais moi j'arrive pas le
côté en plus parfois they say
je trouve parfois que des potes un pote
à l'appli on regarde mais plusieurs
autour du portable ont fait machin tout
et parfois des détails dans une photo
genre la tchèque je vois la ceinture de
la meuf comme les ridicules trier tout
est en fait c'est alors que quand tu
penses de - taggeurs d'europe évidemment
tu es un truc ridicule quand tu vois
donc en fait j'ai l'impression qu'on gap
macro excellent elle fait un leader et
je continue donc ouais de limiter en
fait la rencontre un algorithme ce que
raconte le film aussi un je crois que
une rencontre c'est un truc beaucoup
plus
abstrait mystérieux impalpable est
beaucoup plus beau que juste voir 1
millions pixels aggloméré mettre un peu
d'ordre
cette espèce de barrières qui peut y
avoir de quelqu'un me reconnais mais que
moi je connais pas du tout on fait
passer quelques mots si c'est vous
devrez rencontre ça c'est assez bonne
ouïe très vite en fait tu vois mais si
on rencontre une fille j'étais adoré
dans tel film tel fils tel film tu vas
trouver ça un peu bizarre je suis sûr
qu'elle me plaisent du coup c'est ça le
long de la conversation je me trompe pas
cool merci beaucoup de règles et que moi
que j'ai honte aux idéaux je ne mens pas
en fait c'est pas que je m'inquiète
reçoit d'ailleurs c'est que tous ici
mais c'est que je veux dit comment je
drague c'est qu'en fait j'ai
l'impression de marquer mais je me fais
rien juste j'ai l'impression que
j'envoie des méga signaux alors qu'en
fait j'apprends deux ans plus tard que
la nana en fait un homme qui fait aussi
que comme j'ai bien fait par contre à
fond on va
trop bien mais je suis très bon patriote
et alors est ce que vous vous êtes
beaucoup draguer à lui a sûrement
ah bon ça arrive mais j'aimerais bien
moi qu'on m'aborde plus séparé des
regards the shade jamais à les y obliger
ah ouais non je suis très mal à l'aise
mais quand on voudra et que ce trail
espèce de jeu de je sème tout de suite
ça me casse un peu le
j'aime bien les dragueurs très discret
cool mais moi j'aime bien dans la durée
je vais avoir du mal à draguer une fille
en soi soit très vite on va voir des
shows des voix se rendre compte qu'on se
plaît bon très bien soit sinon il faut
que ce soit un truc où on travaille
ensemble je suis amené à la voir comment
tu vois des vacances hommage un peu trop
d'adolescents où tu prends le temps où
ça se renouvelle un peu plus ça se
reniflent c'est moins sexy comme
expression qui a causé du web je dis
ouah des manifs
ah oui tu vois la renifle le web